trying to pull this story sorry uh this
is from lgbtq nation
explaining the issue they say twitter
enforces its ban on calling people
groomers as anti-lgbtq hate speech
so this is a this is like a cell phone i
mean this is them calling themselves
groomers it's the weirdest thing yeah
the point i made when they announced
this first of all the tweet i put up i
put up before they banned the word
groomer
so they're retroactively enforcing this
now
have they officially put out a policy
saying you cannot use this word i don't
know i've not seen it i've seen the
stories about it but here's here's my
here's the thing i tweeted about i said
there's a creepy guy
staring at kids and look in his lips and
say hey you you groomer you get out of
here and then a bunch of lgbtq people
walk over and go hey why are you making
fun of us and i'm like wait what that's
what's really disturbing i wasn't
talking about you guys people that
groomed children like hitler was a
groomer he groomed children to be in the
hitler youth you know um it doesn't have
anything to do with sexuality on its
face it's only when you can have people
that are sexually grooming but you can
have people that are grooming
politically grooming ideologically and
that it's getting the twitter people
twitter conflating it is very disturbing
to me yeah well that's their own
i don't know if that's a guilty
conscience or if that's bigotry on their
part because they're the ones conflaming
conflating lgbtq
[Music]
struggle with that acronym um with
grooming yeah but this is the point now
you can't call out actual pedophiles
they will suspend you if you so just
call them pedophiles i guess they said
the word groomer's a slur it's like i'm
not trying to slur you i'm trying to
call you what you are yeah i'm not i'm
not about insult i'm like i'm not going
like you're a dumb mfer like that's
that's pointless now i really want to
know what you were quote tweeting
i don't remember um i vaguely remember
and i'm pretty sure it was a picture of
like a drag queen
showing sexual stuff to children i mean
people will find any way to defend that
and i think if we're disagreeing on
something that fundamental like you
can't show this type of thing to
children we've got like
spiritual problems to address a bunch of
left-wing publications are overtly
defending it so let me explain just for
those that haven't heard it before
uh
what grooming is and i'll preface it by
saying for those that are fans who watch
all of the episodes
not every person watches every segment
and every podcast we do and so i often
get the same questions over and over
again for example a lot of people have
said in the past like day or so like i'd
sign up for your website if you didn't
have paypal and i'm like bro we haven't
had paypal for like two weeks now so uh
i'll say this
grooming
is when you take the most base form of
uh
when we're talking about the sexual
grooving of children you take the most
innocuous element of what you want to
introduce to the kids so that no one can
say it's overt
so for instance
i knew a guy who got groomed into being
a male prostitute and how they did it
was they asked him to do a modeling
shoot for 200
a legit true story they said the gig is
we want we're doing a lifestyle photo
shoot we want you to hang out and sit on
this couch
relax have a drink we'll take a few
photos once we're done 200 bucks cash
that's innocent isn't it it's just
he showed up wearing a hoodie and jeans
and just took some photos that was
grooming why
it's the long-term intent the next thing
they did was they said look we already
got tons of these lifestyle photos we
need like we need um like activewear and
swimwear and stuff do you want to try
wearing these shorts and a t-shirt oh
yeah no problem
then they would say sorry man if you
want the money we don't need photos of
this anymore we need you know underwear
models now he's an underwear model
that was grooming so what happens is you
take someone who's doing something adult
or sexualized introducing it to children
so a drag performance what is drag so i
was actually talking about which time i
was earlier go dancing
imagine if someone was like go go
dancing dance or story hour you'd be
like what for kids no way
they get like a woman with just like a
bra and panty sitting there reading the
kids you'd be like maybe not appropriate
hooter is probably not appropriate for
kids either
drag actually involves them taking their
clothes off for money
so when you're talking about a
sexualized uh performer
just reading a book to a kid
the reason that's grooming is the goal
is to normalize the individual in drag
to a child
then when people say hey wait a minute
hold on dragonsexual i said they say all
we're doing is reading books like
exactly what they're doing now the
difference is this is
mass scale
grooming this is big tech and social
media grooming and defending it and i'll
tell you what's really fascinating there
was a period on youtube there's a big
scandal do you remember elsagate do you
know about that is this when
people were like watching some video
maybe i'm mixing i remember there was
something on youtube where people were
watching
i don't know if it was like videos of
kids doing stuff in like swimming pools
there was something i can't explain it
well there was something
on youtube
uh so elsa gate was when all of these
channels started making videos of elsa
the joker and spider-man running around
and the incredible hulk
and they were uh there was like no
dialogue and it was because little kids
their parents would turn the video on
and then it would just generate a ton of
ad revenue for the person so all of a
sudden people started making these
videos because it made money and it was
getting increasingly creepy eventually
it ended with
uh it also got to the point where elsa
was pregnant and the joker was injecting
her with things
no joke okay
this turned into videos where people
literally were giving children shots
because it was generating clicks for
whatever reason the algorithm was
promoting it and then when the when the
people when people realized they could
use an ai to auto generate these videos
you ended up with videos of toddlers
drinking urine
and other overtly so this was a huge
scandal where content for children was
showing gore violence and overtly sexual
activities
youtube panicked and had to start
purging these channels and these videos
to get rid of all of it
so now the clever thing happened among
the groomers
they said
so long as you're doing these things
overtly they'll shut you down what you
need is a shield so we started to see
the lgbtp movement when pedophiles
started saying lgbtp we then saw a ted
talk from a woman who claimed that pedos
were just expressing a natural
orientation
then we saw usa today write a similar
article then we saw i think it was maybe
it was salon and a bunch of magazines
it was a lot of times new york times i
think did it where they started saying
hey hey it's just an orientation trying
to normalize they're maps
minor attracted people right and then
maps popped up on twitter yeah twitter
allows that overtly and people call them
out twitter doesn't care they still
allow it now twitter will actively ban
you if you call out the pedophiles going
after children not only that there's
like a huge amount of not safe for work
content on twitter i understand that
that's part of their tos that they allow
that but they also have a lot of
accounts that openly
say in their bio that they are underage
or their age
um
it's like
as low as like
13 like 12 13 14 year olds having like
these not safe for work accounts
on twitter
it's freaking and they allow it there's
another there's another big issue that's
happening too with um the vr chat stuff
where 13 year olds will be in these vr
chat rooms with grown adults and the
adults can it's unsupervised i mean this
is getting out of control man yeah
this is crazy i mean
this leads to a wider conversation just
about
some of the some of the some of the
challenges with with technology
just in general i think
i think people often forget just how new
this all is that the smartphone and
social media combo we've only had for 15
years
we've had the internet for longer than
that but with all the
greatness and wonderful opportunities it
brings for decent people and
entrepreneurs and creatives and so on
it also opens up this pandora's box
of just
completely new like what you described
with that elsagate thing yeah i mean
that just
yeah it's so bizarre and weird it's not
something you'd think of when you're
starting youtube you're not there
thinking like oh okay this is something
we need to be careful of it wasn't just
videos of people either there were like
animated cartoons that were
made by ais that just generated whatever
got the most clicks and then that ended
up of course being like the most fw yeah
like i don't know like like i didn't
drink drinking
sexual stuff violent stuff yeah like i'm
pretty into technology and i did not
know that such an ai even exists that
you can create automated animated videos
yeah using like characters from disney
and stuff so they know that kids are
going to click on it yeah it's scary and
then you bring in vr
it wasn't about clicking on it what
happens is or autoplay yup yeah yeah so
parents would give their toddlers or
babies a tablet
and then turn on nursery rhymes
and then the algorithm would just
bring those kids down a rabbit hole yo
those kids are going to grow up and be
twisted so the parents just like come
into the room and they just see their
child watching
some wild stuff all the comments were
were gibberish because the babies were
just hitting the thing randomly a lot of
people thought that some of those
gibberish comments were
speaking in some kind of code that was
like coordinating human trafficking
i don't know about that
maybe honestly
these things like that's the one line
for me where i mean i think any any
adult should be like this but when it
comes to people was messing with kids in
general that's just where like
dude
it's been said like why is that partisan
you know if you think about that like it
shouldn't be it should be instinctual
that's when but it's becoming part have
you noticed that many of these these
these people these leftists use cartoon
child avatars yes yeah yeah i had a
bunch of them after after me today in
fact they they they don't make like they
don't they don't view themselves as
adults i mean think about the word
adulting
to him to imply that you're doing
something not normal yo the word
adulting implies like the actual word
means doing normal things humans do yeah
i'm adulting what is children it's just
extended adolescence yes right and so
now you've got people who go on twitter
and they post these pictures of
themselves these fictionalized versions
it was a really funny meme a while ago
from
a particular feminist podcast
and they made this graphic of themselves
and they were all like dainty young
looking women and then someone made a
realistic version of what they actually
looked like like double chin and obese
and things like that people use the
internet to project what they wish they
were
the crazy thing is
and you probably know this better than
anybody zubi people could just be what
they what they want to be by through
hard work right if you want to be thin
and small you just do it not everybody
can be a giraffe though and some people
want to be a giraffe and so i don't tell
you man just pray the matrix and
neuralink can take you into that reality
where you can be a giraffe but for the
time yeah do you think that maybe
some people have this kind of michael
jackson syndrome where like in their
childhood
perhaps they didn't get to play outside
and have toys and do all the things that
they
kind of wanted to and now as an adult
they're
uh trying to play this now
i don't know it's just an idea i just
messing kids childhoods up they're not
they're not being able to enjoy them
properly i think that's definitely
screwing kids up and every all the all
the drugs but i think what's happening
is the internet and media has created
these parallel realities that children
live in
so i often think about you know how is
it that somebody wants to dress up like
a cartoon rabbit yeah you like the like
like furries it's freaking weird man why
i hey look do do what you want to do i
got no beef no it's not beef but it's
[ __ ] weird like we can we can say
stuff is weird i'm not saying it should
be illegal it's just weird i'm just
wondering where it comes from how is
that someone identifies as a cartoon
animal so the first thing that happened
was when i first heard about furries
someone told me it's people who just
dress up like animals and i was like i
guess people want to be animals and then
i actually saw what they were doing and
i'm like no those are looney tunes
they're dressing up like bugs bunny with
big eyes and cartoon faces so what i
think happened was
people grew up watching
anthropomorphized animals
and a child's brain is trying to connect
itself to reality so
in early human development
human tribes the baby watches the adults
do adult stuff
and then says this is what i should be
doing and then wise itself to identify
alongside what their adults are the man
is chopping wood the woman is you know
raising the kids and gathering the men
come back with the bears and the bores
and the meat
then you to the modern era where kids
are now put in front of the car of the
tv where they watch nothing but looney
tunes
their brain says this is adult life
these are what human adults do and so
their brain creates an identity around
anthropomorphized cartoon animals then
when they're older they want to be that
i think this is why we're seeing the
explosion of identity crisis from uh you
guys know what other kin is yes i do
unfortunately
people think they're like i'm i'm an owl
wolf yeah why no no for real like
legitimate question like where does that
identity crisis come from come from but
but isn't it but we've had anthro
morphin's eyes that's one word i always
struggle to anthropomorphism
anthropomorphism yeah we've we've had
that for that's existed for a lo for a
long time though we have american
culture people would become wolves and
things like that not the way and also
didn't we all also grow up with this and
none of us are not so so for one no we
didn't always have this okay we had the
concept of humanized or
anthropomorphized animals in like
written lit literature told to you in a
story from a person's mouth but we had
the cartoons i mean looney tunes and all
the disney stuff so perhaps the issue is
one some people are more susceptible and
two maybe some of these people were
placed in front of these shows for
extended periods of time and their
parents were less attentive on like a
mood stabilizer a lot of that's
pharmaceutical and then kids are seeing
porn average age as 11 that kids are
being exposed to porn
that's another tech thing isn't it
groomers i mean
that's another tech that's another
technology problem man i mean it's all a
tech problem yeah i mean well hold on 20
years ago i mean if you wanted to if you
wanted to access porn as a horny little
12 year old or 13 year old you could do
it but if there were the barrier was a
lot higher you'd have to get an older
person to go in and buy a magazine off
the top shelf or someone has to or
someone's got a little dvd or something
like that not just you tap a site on it
on a phone or a tablet or a computer and
just boom no verification nothing is
just there bill maher asked the question
he said why he said either we're
creating them or we're or we're
creating them or shaming them why is it
that california has so many trans kids
ohio doesn't there's clearly that
something affects the identity of a
young person as they're growing up it's
the parents
it's the parents putting it i think it's
i think it's everything it's parent it's
parents and and society of social media
is affected some of these teachers
obviously are doing this um but a lot of
parents are
it to me it's like having a vegan cat
right if you've got if you've got a
vegan cat it's it's not the cat making
the dessert will die yeah that can't be
vegan well it's not the cat making the
decisions it's like no you
you you're pushing your ideology onto
your cat if you have a trans
three-year-old and i feel gross even
saying that then that is the parents
doing that well well now you've got
scientific journals saying kids can do
transit too this stuff is evil man and i
there's something really satanic going
on in the west right now man like i
can't really put it any
lighter why do you say satanic
i say satanic because i genuinely think
there are evil forces
out there and i'm talking about actual
spiritual realm
um and to someone who is a
absolute atheist a non-believer or
thinks nothing is supernatural that
might sound weird to them but i think
that we've legit got like a demonic
issue and it makes sense that they would
go for children first yeah i i think
there's an entire inversion agenda
that's been running like very
aggressively thanks for checking out
this clip from timcast irl come hang out
live monday through friday at 8 pm
eastern time super chat we'll even
answer some of your questions if you
want to check out the after hours
censored show go to timcast.com and
become a member we put those up monday
through thursday at 11 pm they're very
funny not very family friendly we'll
love to see you there thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time